[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec vous au
rayonnement de chiny bonjour bonjour est
notre invité cette semaine et fabien gay
vous êtes sénateur communiste de
seine-saint-denis bienvenus et cette
semaine à la loi logement était examiné
à l'assemblée nationale avec deux villes
débat sur le logement social
les députés ont validé l'objectif du
gouvernement d'augmenter le nombre de
logements sociaux vendus
la question de la loi sru s'est
également invitée dans les débats le
sénat a largement adopté la réforme
ferroviaire la ministre elisabeth borne
n'a pas caché sa satisfaction saluant un
travail étroit avec le sénat la
commission mixte paritaire chargée de
trouver un compromis entre députés et
sénateurs aura lieu lundi après son
adoption à l'assemblée le projet doit
asile et immigration arrive au sénat ils
étaient examinés en commission cette
semaine la majorité sénatoriale entend
bien durcir un texte qu'elle juge trop
laxistes
de quoi laisser présager des débats
houleux en séance à partir du 19 juin et
les députés sont au bord de l'épuisement
le calendrier législatif chargé de ces
dernières semaines les amène à siéger
tous les jours de la semaine week-end
compris françois de rugy appelle le
gouvernement à mettre de l'ordre dans
l'ordre du jour des textes et cette
semaine à l'assemblée elle les députés
ont donc examiné le projet de loi
logement
[Musique]
la loi est lent pour évolution du
logement aménagement numérique a suscité
de vifs débats dans l'hémicycle
son objectif affiché relancer la
construction de logements mais le volet
consacré au logement social divise
profondément les députés la gauche
accuse le gouvernement de détricoter la
loi sru et de brader le logement social
les explications de sophie béchir cette
loi est la première depuis 18 ans qui en
plusieurs endroits de la loi j'y
reviendrai touche à ce qui était un
totem de la république française ce
totem c'est la loi solidarité
renouvellement urbain plus connus comme
loi sru un texte né en 2000 qui impose
aux communes un minimum de 25 % de
logements sociaux
l'article 43 de la loi et l'on prévoit
d'allonger de cinq à dix ans la durée
pendant laquelle les logements vendus
aux locataires seront prises en compte
dans ce pourcentage
un cadeau fait aux communes qui ne
respectent pas la loi selon la france
inscrivit cette histoire est un
camouflage pour vous qui en réalité
permet de masquer le fait que vous allez
baisser le taux nécessaire pour
atteindre la loi sru et baisser le
nombre de logements sociaux du côté du
gouvernement on veut encourager les
communes à vendre leurs logements
sociaux l'objectif atteindre les 40
mille ventes par an contre huit mille
aujourd'hui pour financer de nouvelles
constructions la durée actuelle de 5 ans
est en effet bien trop courte pour
permettre à un maire de reconstituer le
stock le stock parents des sceaux
logements sociaux vendus
mais à droite on regrette que cette
nouvelle loi ne reviennent pas davantage
sur la loi sru qui imposerait trop
d'obligations aux communes les 25 % de
logements sociaux imposé dans cette loi
sont inadaptées et disproportionnée en
fonction des territoires
certaines communes sont obligés de
construire des logements sociaux alors
qu'elles n'ont plus de terrain pouvant
supporter de nouvelles constructions
le vote sur l'ensemble du texte est
prévu mardi prochain à bien gai cette
loi et l'on remettait en cause les
principes de la loi sru
oui et pas que si une remise en cause en
fait de notre histoire de france
il faut bien comprendre qu'on ait modèle
social et le modèle du logement unique
en europe
il repose sur deux pieds la jambe public
et la jambe privé ce qui nous a permis
la jeune public de répondre à une crise
du logement notamment en 1954 avec
l'appel de l'abbé pierre
l'agent public a pu permettre la
construction de logements aussi en 2008
avec la crise des sub prime
je rappelle que les organismes hlm ont
déstocké cinquante mille logements
sociaux auprès des promoteurs
sinon elle mettait la clé sous la porte
et donc la loi sru
ç'a permis quoi ça permis de construire
entre 500 et 600 mille logements depuis
18 ans et donc c'est cette remise en
cause de cette jambe public
on est en train de libéraliser de
privatiser de donner toutes les clés du
logement social au privé est en réalité
on va pas répondre à une crise du
logement qui une des premières
préoccupations des françaises et des
français
aujourd'hui à 4 millions de françaises
et français qui sont mal logées dans 900
mille sont privées de logement
individuel 12 millions de françaises et
français sont aussi en cause la loi sru
mais oui mais il s'en défend mais par
plusieurs par plusieurs choses
d'abord on va imposer de 2,2 devant
quarante mille logements sociaux on le
sait ça va dégrader un certain nombre de
logements et de d2 parc de logements
sociaux parce qu'ici pour pouvoir en
construire de nuit mais c'est un
désengagement de l'état parce qu'on dit
clairement c'est cette vente qui va
permettre de dégager de dieu dollar
avant la 3 construit ses larmes mais oui
mais c'est un désengagement encore de
l'état parce que ses antécédents il ça
fait des copropriétés dégradées
regardez dans certains quartiers
populaires la vente de ces logements
et si une dégradation totale des
conditions de vie des gens et donc la
loi sru elle est attaquée à sa racine
parce que vous l'avez dit dans notre
reportage l'article 24
c'est à dire que pour un certain nombre
de communes qui ne respectent déjà pas
la loi sru
on vendra qu'on vendra le logement on va
passer de cinq à dix ans c'est à dire
que pendant dix ans ça sera encore
considéré comme un logement social donc
qu'est ce que vont dire les communautés
ne respecte pas mais un très bon bande
vont venir constructeurs vont vendre le
logement social et dire regardez on
respecte la loi et en réalité on ne
construira plus de logement social il ya
une crise du logement
crise de la cherté du logement il ya
besoin de plus de logement social dans
notre pays et qui soit mieux répartie
sur nos territoires
on ne répondra pas cette crise là je le
disais 4 millions de mal-logés 12
millions en situation de précarité
énergétique
mais c'est sur quatre le budget logement
de la france c'est 42 milliards d'euros
est ce que jacques mézard à tort de
vouloir que ce secteur s'autofinance
mais écoutez le logement social c'est
quoi c'est pas le logement que pour les
pauvres c'est le logement pour 72 % des
salariés c'est le logement pour toutes
et tous
si une garantie de la mixité sociale et
donc il ya besoin un certain nombre de
personnes ne peuvent pas se loger dans
le parc privé
moi je le vois un certain nombre par
exemple j'habite à blanc mesnil ne
peuvent pas se loger dans le parc privé
il ya besoin de logement social en 2016
y avait près de deux millions de
demandeurs de logement social vous savez
combien ont été répondues 500 milles
c'est à dire qu'un million cinq cent
mille françaises et français
on était en attente d'un logement social
en france en 2016 et ces chiffres
continuent de croître d'année en année
parce que il ya un besoin fort de
logement social est en vérité il ya une
décroissance de la construction de
logement social donc c'est ça la réalité
juste un mot sur un autre point
polémique de la loi est la réduction de
100 % à 10 % du nombre de logements
neufs accessibles aux handicapés
c'est là aussi une mise en mal de la loi
handicap mais évidemment parce que c'est
ça qui a il ya choqué tout le monde il
ya la loi sru reviennent en parler mais
quelqu'un qui atteint logement social et
qui en situation de handicap
aujourd'hui bon il ya déjà cette
difficulté de pouvoir accéder à un
logement social je vais le dire sur 4
peut avoir un logement social ça veut
dire que trois sur quatre soit en
attente
et quand on est en situation de handicap
on va avoir la double peine parce qu'il
faudra attendre plus qu'un logement
social qui soient adaptées pour le
handicap soit libéré donc ça sera la
double peine est en réalité nous avons
posé la question hier avec dominique
watrin sénateur communiste du pas de
calais au gouvernement nous leur avons
dit comment vous allez faire ils ont dit
mais vous inquiétez pas qu'il y aura un
logement social de libre et qui sera pas
adapté
eh bien il faudra il faudra le financer
on lui a posé la question mais qui le
financera le parc social où les gens
situation dans dit
on n'a pas eu de réponse donc ça c'est
une vraie véritable question voilà je
c'est une loi mauvaise de bout en bout
240 voix pour 85 contre mardi le sénat a
adopté la réforme ferroviaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
adoptée mais modifier le sénat a tenu à
imprimer sa marque sur cette réforme il
a notamment renforcé les garanties
accordées aux salariés en cas de
transfert vers une autre entreprise et
améliorer le volet aménagement du
territoire
tout cela en bonne entente avec le
gouvernement sans brassard car pour
l'adoption 240 contre 85 le sénat a
adopté la réforme de la sncf adopté au
sénat par la droite majoritaire
les groupes de gauche le ps notamment
ont voté contre
ainsi les sénateurs entérine un peu plus
le projet de loi est valide les trois
principes vivement contesté par les
cheminots la fin du recrutement au
statut l'ouverture à la concurrence et
la transformation de la sncf en société
anonyme
le gouvernement n'a pas caché sa
satisfaction je souhaite ici saluer
notre travail commun qui a été très
constructif
chacun dans son rôle partageant le même
objectif de faire avancer la réforme
notamment en vue d'apporter des réponses
aux questions que les cheminots pouvait
encore se poser car sur ce texte
l'exécutif et le sénat ont travaillé
main dans la main plusieurs amendements
ont été déposés avec l'aval du
gouvernement et sur proposition des
syndicats réformistes
le sénat a mis vraiment la réforme sur
de bons rails pour toutes les avancées
sociales validé par la mini il faut
savoir arrêter une grève une
co-construction qui ne passe pas dans
les rangs de la gauche claude malhuret
qui se réjouit du rôle du sénat dans
cette sortie de crise attaque au passage
durement les communistes
[Musique]
camarades et c'est une défaite cuisante
pour ceux qui ont organisé la pire des
formes de grève la grève à répétition
destiné à pourrir au maximum et le plus
longtemps possible la vie de nos
concitoyens
le 11 juin prochain aura lieu la
commission mixte paritaire chargée de
trouver un compromis entre députés et
sénateurs une version définitive de la
loi attendue par les syndicats pour
décider de stopper ou non la grève ont
besoin d'entendre un claude malhuret qui
a prononcé un véritable réquisitoire
finalement contre votre groupe
est-ce que vous ne payez pas votre
attitude qui pour certains puits
s'apparente à de l'obstruction pendant
ces débats
non mais on n'a pas moi je parlerais pas
de monsieur malhuret n'est pas très
intéressant plutôt que de traîner à
l'elysée y aurait mieux fait d'être
trois jours dans l'hémicycle pour
argumenter face à nous sincèrement on a
été les seuls à combattre pied à pied
cette réforme ferroviaire au sénat sur
le triptyque imposé par le gouvernement
ouverture à la concurrence on l'a
démontré partout ça a été fait en europe
ça a été destructeur d'abord pour le
rail partout des petites lignes ont
fermé l'explosion des prix des
dégradations des conditions de
transports pour les usagers des
dégradations de travail pour les
salariés
on a aussi le statut des cheminots on
nous a dit ça coûte des millions et des
millions en réalité entre 10 et 15
millions et nous l'avons prouvé
c'est une réforme dogmatique sur cette
question là parce que ça coûtera plus
cher en vérité on devrait parler
aujourd'hui de l'augmentation des
salaires des cheminots parce qu'être
sous payé pour travailler nuit et jour
et week-end a justifié ce statut est une
ligne rouge si finalement les cheminots
seraient mieux payé ce n'est pas ce
qu'il ya c'est ce qu'on a dit l'or lors
des débats c'est un scalp des cheminots
ils veulent envoyer un message clair ne
luttez pas dans ce pays pendant cinq ans
nous allons vous passez un rouleau
compresseur et ils savent que les
cheminots sont extrêmement mobilisés
donc c'est ça et c'est une réforme que
dogmatique et la dernière chose c'est la
transformation de la société des 3 epic
en société anonyme
là aussi personne ne demande ni les
usages ireny l'union européenne
personnes et nous l'avons dit à madame
la ministre nous a pas répondu quand
vous allez transformer les 3 epic en
société anonyme
vous savez vous allez dégrader la dette
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on
emprunte quand la sncf on prête elle est
gagée sur l'état
quand vous serez société anonyme les
marchés vous prêteront à un taux plus
fort donc il n'ya pas y'a pas de ce
n'est pas raisonner en serre en termes
d'intérêt général en termes de
développement durable comprends votre
position fin janvier mais est ce que le
travail de la majorité sénatoriale de
droite n'a pas rendu cette réforme plus
acceptable pour vous oui vous rigolez
monsieur cornu a parlé d'avancée sociale
moi je les dis seuls 2000 hercules les
gammes haïti sur le volontariat mais
vous casser le droit de retour encore
attend des avancées sociales dans ce
pays ça se respecte ce mot on est en
france encore une fois on a une histoire
c'est 1936 et 1940 5,6 1968 c'est la
liberté syndicale
c'est l'école j'ai payé s'est pas mis
rochus social où on casse le statut des
cheminots qui ont leur dis bon
finalement nous aurait pas trop de trois
ans pour intégrer le statut vous aurez
huit ans non mais tout ça et de la
tambouille
et c'est une concession d'ailleurs fait
au mouvement social parce qu' il dure il
dure ce mouvement justement si je vous
entends bien vous enjoignent et les
cheminots à poursuivre ce nouvel an mais
moi non je l' ai déjà dit dans
l'hémicycle et je le répète sur ce
plateau ceni au sénat comme décide
d'arrêter un mouvement de grève et c'est
pas sur ce plateau comme décide de
poursuivre si aux cheminots et aux
cheminots et leurs organisations
syndicales de dessiner un avis personnel
il est temps que la grève s'arrête où
elle doit y est je le redis plusieurs
hommes de droite claudie et femmes de
droite sénatrices et sénateurs de droite
ont rejoint les cheminots et cheminots
tas a arrêté la grève mais c'est pas
dans les hémicycles ni sur les plateaux
télé comme des crétins soyons sérieux
mais franchement cette réforme elle va
contre l'intérêt général c'est de ça
qu'il faut parler notre maillage
territorial le droit à la mobilité le
sens écologique vous ne venez pas vous
prononcer sur la grève en revanche il y
aura une commission mixte paritaire
lundi il y aura une nouvelle lecture à
l'assemblée au sénat la semaine
prochaine des conclusions de cette
commission à ce que vous espérez encore
des américains parlement oui la droite
va négocier avec la droite
bon on l'a vu on l'a vu pendant trois
jours dans cet hémicycle heureusement
d'ailleurs qui avait le groupe sérieux
avec notamment illana s'assied guillaume
quintard qui étaient les chefs de file
pour nous et qu'on a mené la lutte sinon
ils avaient envie de tout régler entre
eux et je peux vous dire qu'ils ont été
surpris de la force de notre
argumentaire et de notre détermination
parce que l'or
lente et c'était de tout régler en
catimini en une soirée et on nous avoir
imposé d'avoir un débat de trois jours
c'est normal quand même on est en train
de détricoter dans ce pays 80 ans du
ferroviaire en trois jours je pense que
sa demande ait un vrai débat allait
toujours au sénat mais en commission
cette fois elle les sénateurs ont durci
la loi asile immigration
[Musique]
à la droite sénatoriale a réécrit le
texte asile immigration elle a décidé de
renforcer notamment les conditions de
regroupement familial de réduire le
nombre de visas accordés à certains pays
les détails avec jordan classe le projet
de loi asile et migrations version sénat
se veut plus ferme dans la pratique et
une volonté est affichée par les
sénateurs mieux accueillir les réfugiés
qui bénéficient déjà de la protection de
la france mais surtout lutter plus
efficacement contre l'immigration
irrégulière
nous considérons que le texte du
gouvernement ne traite qu'en partie la
problématique de l'immigration nous le
regrettons nous avons accepté un certain
nombre de mesures dont nous doutons de
l'efficacité comme le prolongement de la
durée de rétention à 90 jours pour
obtenir les laissez passer consulaires
dans cette logique de plus de fermeté
les sénateurs de la droite et du centre
veulent que la décision définitive de
rejet d'une demande d'asile soit
assimilé une obligation de quitter le
territoire ils veulent par ailleurs
organisé chaque année au parlement un
débat pour définir des quotas en
fonction des capacités d'accueil sur le
délit de solidarité
le sénat refuse catégoriquement
d'assouplir la législation déjà en
vigueur tels que le texte est rédigé
aujourd'hui dans le droit positif
l'aide au séjour irrégulier sur le
territoire national c'est ça son vrai
nom aujourd'hui permet au procureur de
la république de poursuivre ceux qui
sont vraiment des auteurs d'un délit et
ceux qui de façon bénévole et spontanées
ont aidé des migrants et ne relève pas
d'une infraction donc le texte en lui
même il permet cette distinction et les
programmes publics veillent à respecter
cette distinction
donc il est inutile d'affaiblir le
dispositif existant concernant les
mineurs isolés
l'idée des sénateurs et d' interdire
strictement leur rétention des
propositions qui promettent des débats
tendus dans l'hémicycle début de
l'examen en séance publique à partir du
19 juin prochain
fabien gay plus de fermeté et de
réalisme c'est l'explication de philippe
bas comment qualifiez-vous ce texte vous
moi je suis extrêmement choqué par ce
texte entend comme de gauche communistes
en tant que citoyen français je suis
choquée des propos de ministres sur le
benchmarking sur le shopping de l'asile
rappelons quand même que ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui fuient les
guerres et les misères et ce sont des
hommes et des femmes comme dit je suis
choqué par je suis citoyen français et
que sur le fronton de nos mairies a
écrit liberté égalité et fraternité je
crois que ça c'est un ciment je suis
choquée parce que le droit d'asile
ces garanties dans notre constitution et
par la convention de genève sur l'asile
en 1951
je suis choquée parce que pour la
première fois dans notre pays on
regroupe asile et immigration
même nicolas sarkozy à qui on doit quand
même le débat sur l'identité nationale
et dont on ne peut pas dire que je sois
un proche de ses idées n'avait même pas
osé faire ça donc honnêtement je suis
choquée parce qu'en plus on court
derrière l'extrême droite une course à
l'échalote on parle au plus bas
instincts et non pas l'intellect
parce que si on parlait à l'intellect
des gens ont leur dirai qu'il faut
accueillir dignement des ces personnes
et ces gens qui fuient la guerre et la
misère
il faut leur dire que 97% des gens qui
se réfugient le fond d'abord dans leur
pays et que nous accueillons en europe
que 3% des réfugiés il faut leur dire
surtout qu'ils aient défis devant nous
d'humanité
la banque mondiale dont peut pas accuser
qu'elle soit communiste vient de rendre
un rapport au mois de mars il dit 148
millions de personnes vont être réfugiés
climatiques à l'horizon 2050
148 millions donc nous allons bien avoir
un problème d'humanité à traiter pour
faire société commune et ça il faut
parler à l'intellect et pas au plus bas
instincts et d'ailleurs là on pourra pas
dire l'extrême droite pour agiter
renvoyés chez eux en moyenne et chez eux
mais ou parce qu'ils n'auront plus taire
puisque tout sera submergée par les eaux
et donc vous voyez bien on est un défi
d'humanité de monde et donc ça ça répond
à une course à l'échalote à l'extrême
droite c'est un jeu très dangereux parce
que l'extrême droite partout en europe
progresse on ad'ailleurs l'extrême
droite au pouvoir en italie donc ce
qu'on est en train de faire là n'est pas
un jeu c'est très dangereux ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire est ce que vous
l'avez j'accepte a mené une vague
populiste en france aussi ben je moi je
pense que quand on court derrière les
idées d'extrême
un moment donné on préfère toujours
l'original à la copie donc je vais
prévient le gouvernement que sur ce
terrain là ils jouaient le jeu très dans
l'air le pont pourtant les sondages
montrent que les français sont d'accord
avec la on est dense et gérard collomb
sur les micro et on est dans une crise
économique l'opinion ce que pense
l'opinion garonne mais mais être
politique c'est pas abonder dans le sens
et parler au plus bas instincts
on est dans une crise économique on leur
dit que le véritable problème c'est pas
le banquier c'est pas les exilés fiscale
avec les 80 milliards d'euros planqués
dans les paradis fiscaux dont le second
gouvernement ne fait rien pour aller les
chercher ce qui arrive aux autres et
beaucoup de problèmes en leur dit que
c'est celles et ceux qui fait la guerre
et qui viennent ici on ne parle pas
l'intellect des gens ont par leurs bas
instincts
je le répète et franchement on ne parle
pas des mineurs isolés on va on est la
question du délit de solidarité
on vient de mettre à bas cela au sénat
quand même franchement vous croyez que
nos problèmes dans ce pays c'est cédric
héron non bon alors soyons un peu
sérieux
on reviendra sur ses textes dans cette
émission puisqu'il sera examiné au sénat
à partir du 19 juin
dernière chose quand même on touche les
droits fondamentaux les droits
fondamentaux humains
un mineur est ce qu'on est d'accord
quand même que dans ce pays est mineur
avant qu'il soit réfugié
c'est un mineur jusqu'à l'âge de ses 18
ans c'est ça la question
franchement moi je j'abonde dans le sens
de jacques toubon on ne peut pas dire la
non plus qu'il soit de mon camp mais ils
disent et la dignité humaine celle des
droits fondamentaux qui sont attaqués
nous nous défendrons pied à pied cela
dans l'hémicycle on a bien compris votre
position fabien gay ont fini donc la
semaine avec les députés au bord du
surmenage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop de lois tuent la loi les députés
proteste compte un calendrier législatif
chargé qui les amène à siéger tous les
jours au risque de nuire à la qualité
des débats parlementaires mari la bat
des députés au bord du surmenage au
risque d'affaiblir la qualité des
travaux parlementaires entre les textes
asile et migrations agriculture et
alimentation entre le projet de loi
logement et bientôt celui sur la
formation professionnelle
le rythme des débats parlementaires et
trop soutenu pour le président de
l'assemblée nationale
nous avons siégé trois week-ends
successifs quinze jours successifs
les députés ne se plaignent pas de trop
travailler nous voulons simplement qu'il
y ait un fonctionnement correct de notre
assemblée et de nos débats d'où sa
proposition
arrêtez de siéger les week-ends une
décision qui fait consensus à droite
comme à gauche le débat c'est est ce que
on légifère dans de bonnes conditions
est ce que l'on fait bien la loi dans
ces conditions la réponse unanime ans et
non c'est vrai point journalistes les
vrais pour un médecin c'est vrai pour la
députée n'est pas des surhommes mais pas
deux sur fable le calendrier tellement
mal foutu que tout tombe en même temps
nous n'avons plus les moyens d'exercer
correctement et de faire vivre
correctement la démocratie puisque la
moindre des choses c'est de pouvoir
défendre des arguments mais pour les
députés du front national devenu
rassemblement national
le président de l'assemblée se trompe de
débat très bien de se pencher sur
l'organisation des travaux de
l'assemblée c'est à dire l'incapacité
pour les députés du rassemblement
national obtenir du temps de parole pour
discuter la loi landes la loi logement
en particulier l incapacité à pouvoir
avoir un groupe ce sont les conditions
même du travail législatif qui ne sont
pas opérante
la mesure devrait entrer en application
seulement pour ce week end
mais pour le moment aucune autre séance
n'a été planifiée le dimanche
d'ici la fin de la session parlementaire
établir la pelouse un reportage le
dolorisme au choix et mari la bat fabien
gay le gouvernement doit-il mettre de
l'ordre dans cet ordre du jour pour moi
sur le bord notent j'ai vu que c'était
surtout les députées remarche qui se
plaignait députés la majorité moi je
leur propose de créer un syndicat cgt
pour aller discuter avec richard ferrand
leur président de groupe et puis surtout
christophe castaner c'est vrai que là on
a quand même un moment donné moi je le
vois dans ma commission au sénat pendant
quelques mois on n'a pas eu de grands
textes et puis là d'un coup on a deux
textes lois agriculture et alimentation
et puis la loi et est habilitée
mais sincèrement parler de burnout moi
je viens d'une famille d'ouvriers
franchement être parlementaire c'est
moins compliqué que être aujourd'hui un
fermier harkis ou policier ou juge ou
encore salariés du privé je pense aux
carrefours je pense aux ford aux pages
jaunes angie de leurs emplois et
menaçait 80 heures par semaine 17 jours
d'affilée non mais il ya une véritable
c'est ce sont de bonnes conditions pour
fabriquer alors non il ya une véritable
question c'est au tour des personnels de
nos assemblées et des collaborateurs qui
eux par contre c'est vrai que c'est un
rythme de vie effréné pour pour elle et
moi je vois les personnels du sénat sont
des gens extrêmement dévoués d'une
gentillesse incroyable et d'un
professionnalisme mais c'est vrai que
quand on arrive jour/nuit et puis les
week-ends sais c'est pas des conditions
de travail décentes
alors je le pont des arts un peu mes
propos c'est vrai que pour les
parlementaires
il faut à rejoindre le gouvernement à
mieux travailler le il est évidemment
évidemment vous avez tout compris
alors c'est un peu mieux gérer quand
même au sénat je le dois reconnaître que
monsieur larcher fait le travail c'est
peut-être un monsieur de rugy maintenant
devoir avait monsieur caster puisqu'ils
appartiennent à la même majorité de
regarder comment il faut mieux le
calendrier à l'assemblée nationale est
ce qu'il ya une part de responsabilité
des parlementaires eux mêmes quand on
voit 3400 amendement sur la loi est lent
oui bien sûr madame
et puis un jour on ne passera plus rien
on ne dépassera plus de rien non ces
sondés par exemple sur l'eau agriculture
eau soit élan je pense qu'on a le droit
d'avoir un débat
maintenant c'est au gouvernement de
mieux préparer les séances et de mieux
l'ordonnancé sur sur l'année il nous y
franchement les textes succède à une
rapidité folle où c'est vrai que vous
allez même plus le temps d'aller au plus
profond des textes ça c'est une vraie
question rapidement vous avez pointé du
doigt christophe castaner est-ce que sa
double casquette de secrétaire d'état
aux relations avec le parlement et de
chefs de partis l'empêchent de jouer
pleinement son rôle auprès des mots ce
jour sur les commentaires le buzz
politique je laisse aux dents mais sans
commenter mais je suis prêt à me demande
tu as tort elle s'inquiète parlementaire
vous trouvez christophe castaner joue
bien moi je moi je m'étonne moi je joue
et autres quand même que mes ministres
relation par le monde parle jamais avec
le parlementaire par exemple moi je vois
mon gros puis nous a jamais reçus
parce que ces véritables questions s'est
jamais arrivé sous la vème république
au moins ministre aux relations avec les
parlementaires dont va au moins pas
discuter avec les parlementaires ça
c'est sûr merci à vous fabien gay
d'avoir fait le tour de cette actualité
parlementaire et politique avec nous
merci à vous en riant et on a l'air vous
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]